un deuil impossible une émotion trop
lourde à porter
pink floyd tenais à venir visiter le
lieu où est mort son frère john il lui a
fallu une semaine pour trouver la force
et le courage de le faire aider par son
pasteur comme un long chemin de croix où
chaque pack coûte
il s'avance lentement dans la fresque
peinte sur un mur adjacent
un moment de silence puis un sa vie
acclamé soutenu par la foule
le frère éplorée reprend sa marche vers
l'endroit où john floyd a poussé son
dernier souffle sous le poids d'un
policier blanc il pose le genou par
terre
et puis ce cri l'expression d'une
douleur trop longtemps contenue terrain
floyd est venu à minneapolis
parce qu'il avait besoin de sentir la
présence de son frère mais il avait
aussi un message à transmettre à la
communauté et plus particulièrement aux
émeutiers ce que vous faites ne sert à
rien dit il
ça ne va pas ramener mon frère à chaque
cas de brutalité policière poursuit-il
c'est toujours pareil vous protestez
vous détruisez des trucs mais rien ne
change
alors cette fois ci faisant autrement
arrêté pensez que votre foi ne compte
pas conclut-il
et allez voter voilà comment les aura
car nous sommes nombreux
des mots qui font mouche dans une
communauté depuis trop longtemps vidé de
tout espoir une riposte par les urnes
donc mais aussi en justice la famille de
john floyd exige que soit inculpé de
meurtre les quatre policiers
responsables de sa mort
et présente à l'appui ce rapport
d'autopsié indépendant accablant est
mort par asphyxie conclut le médecin
légiste c'est un homicide en l'avocat de
la famille
une conclusion s'impose des poings
ils veulent des accusations de meurtre
au premier degré dit il car la vie des
noirs et celle de georges compte qu'est
bolano ce rêve d'une justice et d'une
police au service de tous
mais elle se dit réaliste alors elle a
emmené ses trois enfants sur le lieu du
crime pour les préparer au monde dans
lequel ils vont grandir on ne veut pas
les exposer à ça dit elle mais c'est la
réalité notre société il faudra du temps
pense-t-elle avant que les choses
changent et d'ici là malheureusement
combien d'autres victimes
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
minneapolis